thanks to surf shark for helping support
this episode
take this particle make it the opposite
charge turn it the other way but it's
not the anti-particle it's the other
it's the other anti-particle right it's
this other one but then you gotta take
it flip it around shove it in a hole
right
and then we have a cute little acronym
that we call it right
[Music]
hey crazies welcome to another
installment of wife reacts this is my
wife awkward m hello today i'm going to
be explaining dark matter to her let's
see how this goes let's okay so first
off i guess what exactly do you know
about dark matter just so we can get a
bass line here it doesn't emit light
there's a lot of it
yes
i know that vera rubin
who's an important lady
that i think that's it that's about it
okay but before i get into this because
i know there's going to be a bunch of
people
that are going to mention this in the
comments
you know who you are
it is entirely possible that we don't
understand gravity as well as we think
we do sure that is possible but
the ways in which we would have to
change our models of gravity to explain
all of the things that dark matter
explains
is it it's absurd it is actually less
work to just accept dark matter right
and so it's it's possible that we don't
understand gravity and it's possible
that maybe one of the things that we
attribute to dark matter is just could
just be explained by modified gravity
like one thing
but not all of them sure and so most
models that include some kind of
modified version of gravity also include
dark matter because they know that it
can't explain everything okay so we're
not saying that modified gravity doesn't
exist at all right it just is not a full
explanation
of all of the effects of dark matter
correct okay
all right so then the question remains
what exactly is it prepare yourself for
some acronyms oh love a good acronym
here we go oh they're the silly ones
aren't they yes oh no okay candidate
number one
machos right
which stands for massive and compact
halo objects okay the halo is a region
of the galaxy outside of the disk
side of the disk the galaxy is spun into
a disk a spiral disk which is where most
of the luminous matter is and then the
halo is everything outside of that now
there are things out there like i didn't
know there were things out there there
are things out there like they're called
globular clusters it's these clusters of
stars that are really densely packed
there are these objects that are in the
halo of a galaxy and they're massive and
compact
so we're talking things like rogue
planets white dwarfs neutron stars black
holes yes comfortable with that those
are all considered massive and compact
halo objects or machos okay okay so that
okay these are all very ordinary things
right we wanted dark matter to be
ordinary things that we just weren't
seeing sure the problem is we can do
rough estimates right ballpark order of
magnitude estimates of how many of those
things we expect to find
and it's nowhere near enough
the rest of it the rest of the 84 of
matter that is dark matter has to be
something more exotic
based on our evidence of dark matter it
has a few properties that we can say
conclusively about it
now we call it dark matter but it should
really be called invisible matter it's
actually legit invisible it doesn't
interact with light
at all it does not block out the light
if the light is behind it right like you
would expect for like a planet or
something like that exactly or some like
dense dark nebulous cloud it's not like
that it must not interact with light we
usually say at all but technically it
could a little bit
but in a way that's below our ability to
detect which is weird yeah that's weird
and it's a lot lower than normal matter
would interact with light sure and if it
doesn't interact with light it's not
electromagnetic at all
that means we can't put it in a
container either
why
because the reason that your hand
doesn't go through things is because of
electro electric propulsion right the
electrons in your hand from your
subatomic particles exactly okay we know
that if it doesn't interact
electromagnetically then it doesn't do
that and so you couldn't put it in the
container it'll just pass right through
the walls of your container not only can
it not be seen it also can't be held do
we have dark matter in our
galaxy absolutely we have dark matter in
our solar system so
i think that already shows us that like
we can't interact with it because it's
apparently here
and yet now there isn't much of it
uh-huh we know what density we should
expect it to have and that density is
extremely small we're talking like if
you took all the dark matter and our
entire solar system out to neptune's
orbit
and you collapsed it into an object okay
it would have the mass of uh medium
medium-sized asteroid which is very
small okay astronomically bigger than i
was anticipating based on what you were
saying
that's pretty small astronomically
speaking okay
but if it doesn't interact
electromagnetically then it wouldn't
ever form an asteroid right why would it
that electromagnetism
is what slows things down and generates
heat and like saps energy away and so if
it doesn't interact electromagnetically
then it doesn't slow down which means it
can't clump the best we can do is just a
diffuse cloud of it a cloud of stuff
that can't be seen and doesn't interact
with anything
except gravity invisible hence invisible
so we can only see it based on its
gravitational effects i mean but have we
actually found its gravitational effects
in the solar system no no because
there's not enough of it okay that makes
sense asteroid mass isn't going to do
much to our solar system which is why we
don't see it here and we don't see it on
a you know a stellar scale either it has
to be an interstellar galactic scale
before we start to see its effects okay
before the scale is large enough that
there's enough mass to actually do
something while technically the dark
matter is here and it is gravitationally
affecting things it's not really that
much there's much much bigger influences
okay
our next category next candidate for
dark matter
they're called wimps
okay
who named these right you needed like
i think they're the coolest acronyms in
in astrophysics hands down nick's over
here like
so wimps are weakly interacting massive
particles they're not big compact
objects they're little tiny particles
and there's just a lot of them you know
what i think i'm really struggling with
massive how can something have a mass if
it doesn't interact electromagnetically
what gives you the impression that
something has to interact
electromagnetically to have mass because
generally we say that things that have
mass are made up of particles
i'm thinking that in order to have mass
you need some protons neutrons and
electrons which is not true
it doesn't have to be electrons neutrons
and protons or quarks or whatever
right there are a lot of particles in
the standard model which is going to be
a big deal today this the yes okay the
big chart you want to throw that up for
them definitely definitely going to
happen
so there's a short list of elementary
particles and then there's a whole long
list of particles that are made from
those particles like protons and
neutrons are not on the elementary
particles list fair enough i'm a
biologist okay that's as far as i need
to go
they're made of smaller particles called
quarks but those quarks only represent
about one percent of the mass of a
proton
the other 99 percent is actually made up
of massless particles called gluons
i don't like it
at all 99 of the mass of a proton is
from massless things the whole concept
of mass it's it's very different on a
quantum level than it is on a normal
level different it's such a polite word
for it
try to leave some of those
preconceptions
you know try to set them aside
no all right all right
i'll accept it i will accept that it is
massive even though it is not made up of
particles or it's made maybe made up of
particles that don't have mass or
whatever or they do have mass but they
don't have any charge and if they don't
have any charge then they can't interact
electromagnetically oh so they could be
neutral yes okay
i'm comfortable with that now neutrons
do interact electromagnetically even
though they're neutral because their
parts aren't the quarks have charge even
though together they form an uh a
neutral particle that makes sense if we
want dark matter to be one of these
wimps one of these weakly interacting
massive particles we need to make it a
massive particle that's an elementary
particle okay that isn't made of charged
parts right
okay i accept this it is made of
particles yes just a neutral particle
that is not made up of any other charged
smaller bits like neutrinos
neutrinos could be dark matter because
they are massive they have mass not very
much but they have mass and they don't
have any charge they're neutral as why
we call them neutrinos okay but they do
interact with something because we can
detect them that's the word i'm looking
for right we do have neutrino detectors
and these they're the big tanks full of
oil basically
these neutrinos
are tiny they're tiny amount of mass and
they are very weakly interacting so even
though we have these giant tanks full of
oil they only detect
one or two neutrinos a day
but there are a hundred trillion
neutrinos passing through your body
every second
that's uh
invasive
just pass that out through torino i did
not consent to this okay
but they're not just passing through
your body they're passing through the
earth right right so these neutrino
detectors detect neutrinos from all
directions including down
some of these neutrinos pass straight
through the earth and then hit a
molecule in the oil and based on what
that interaction eventually emits we
have detectors around the outside of the
tank and we can determine not only the
energy of that neutrino but what
direction it came from so we can know if
it came from up or down we've got
something built into the standard model
that could be
dark matter
so it's not that it doesn't interact it
is that it weakly interacts on such a
small scale
that it's not meaningful until it's
until you have a lot of it right
we've got these things called neutrinos
right and they sort of
they fit the bill they they match what
we expect dark matter to be right
almost oh
no
most neutrinos
are traveling
very very fast
like near the speed of light
and so they're carrying a lot of energy
kinetic energy
and that is not something we expect dark
matter to do
carry kinetic energy or a lot of
connecticut carry a lot of kinetic
energy anything that has mass and moves
around i mean anything that moves around
at all has kinetic energy even photons
of kinetic energy
when we
model what we expect dark matter to look
like we expect it to be something we
call cold dark matter
and by cold we just mean not moving fast
interesting use of words
it's kind of analogous to how thermal
energy works when things are moving
really fast it's hot and when things are
moving slowly it's cold and so it's kind
of just reusable to that yeah we're
using hot and cold analogously like that
and so that makes sense that absolute
zero on the kelvin
scale can i say that yeah kelvin scale
is a complete absence of movement right
aside from some weird quantum
uncertainties yes
because nothing can ever be exactly zero
but yeah so we expect most dark matter
to be cold not moving very quickly so
most of the neutrinos we see don't
actually fit the bill they might be dark
matter but they're not cold dark matter
now this doesn't rule out neutrinos
though there are
slow-moving neutrinos we can't detect
them because in order for them to
actually like the the more energy they
have the more likely they are to
interact in our detectors fair enough
and so we can't actually detect the slow
ones but the idea checks out
mathematically right and we do expect
them to exist
we know that whether or not a neutrino
was affected by with the weak
interaction is
determined by whether or not it's
spinning clockwise or counterclockwise
whether or not it's right-handed or
left-handed okay so only one like only
left-handed or only right-handed right
will interact with the
weak interaction interaction yes okay
you're familiar with that that matter
has an anti-matter partner sure okay
well each one of those the matter and
the anti-matter can spin two different
directions you can have that matter spin
clockwise or counterclockwise you can
have the anti-matter spin clockwise or
counterclockwise only one from each set
is affected by the weak nuclear
interaction
left-handed regular matter is affected
by the weak nuclear interaction and
right-handed anti-matter is affected by
the weak nuclear interaction but the
left-hand anti-matter and the
right-handed regular matter are not sure
they're called sterile okay because they
don't interact with the weak force got
it what's complicated is that we've
talked about so many particles at this
point that my brain is like i don't even
know what particles we're talking i was
i was worried about that i am particle
overloaded this is why people are like
that's ridiculous because this is what
it's not there's so many different like
little things you're like take this
particle make it the opposite charge
turn it the other way but it's not the
anti-particle it's the other it's the
other anti-particle right it's this
other one but then you gotta take it
flip it around shove it in a hole right
and then we have a cute little acronym
that we call it right
yes and it may or may not be real we
don't know no no these are real these
are real okay thanks for letting me get
that off yes
but if the sterile neutrinos don't
interact with the weak force and we
already know they don't interact
electromagnetically they're only going
to interact reputationally they'd be
considered a weakly interacting massive
particle and we do have a tiny tiny bit
of evidence from our neutrino detectors
that they do exist there's enough
evidence to hint that they do there's
enough evidence to say that we should
study that more yes
absolutely but the point is we know that
dark matter has to be there it doesn't
have to be
one thing it could be a combination of
all of these things but the point is
that the overwhelming majority of this
effect must be
matter we know that it's matter because
it's massive right
when things are massive and they can
move around that's what matter is right
right and so we know that it's matter we
just don't know exactly what type of
matter it is and it could be a
combination of things but in terms of
the two broad categories in terms of
machos and wimps we expect dark matter
to be overwhelmingly wimps
but you know what isn't a wimp today's
sponsor surfshark
surfshark is a vpn or virtual private
network which masks your location by
displaying a different ip address to the
public internet
did you know that streaming services
have different libraries for different
regions say you're on netflix in the us
and you want to watch your favorite tv
show brooklyn nine-nine as you can see
it's not available
guess you can't watch it then right
wrong
surf shirt can bypass all this nonsense
all you've got to do is turn on the vpn
switch your ip address to another
country like say the united kingdom
and bam go ahead and watch brooklyn 99
to your heart's delight
you're not limited to one device either
surf shark can be installed and used on
an unlimited number of devices
if this sounds like a service you'd like
to use go to the link in the description
and enter promo code asylum
you'll get 83 off and three extra months
for free which is a good deal it'll also
let surf shark know you heard about them
for me which helps out the channel
thanks for liking and sharing this video
a special thanks goes out to all my
generous patreon patrons and youtube
members for making all this possible
don't forget to subscribe if you'd like
to keep up with us and until next time
remember it's okay to be a little crazy
if the earth could fit in your hand it
would be heavy
yeah i mean subjectively sure
if you kept the earth the same density
it would be a fairly smooth sphere with
a weight somewhere between aluminum and
steel
some people might call that heavy
anyway thanks for watching